thousands of new york city workers
taking to the streets and shouting we
will not comply over vaccine mandates
forcing them to choose between getting
the job or losing their jobs it comes
days before the mandate goes into effect
the nypd's largest police union just
filed a lawsuit to overturn the new rule
and says there are no widespread covet
infections among officers with the
current backs or test policy and fighter
fires excuse me firefighters are not
happy about it either watch
we're not anti-vaxx
we're anti-mandate no one wants this ram
down their throat uh the blind
administration i understand the
president made a statement the other day
i hope he can walk that back i don't
believe i hope he doesn't believe that
first responders should be fired without
the city or the municipality coming to
the table and dealing direct with the
affected unions because we have a lot of
good points that are backed by science
and uh this plan with the testing with a
vaccination plan it works
and then we'll host john oliver mocking
police officers who refuse the vaccine
the police are supposed to be keeping
the public safe that is the point of
their jobs yet some don't seem to give
much
about that if an officer wants to quit
over this
let them let the individuals who clearly
don't care about public safety stop
being in charge of public safety it is
really that simple
one of the things that he said jesse was
that um that if there's a public safety
concern and a shortage that well they
should just be fired but there was
there's been a shortage for the nypd
because of one the pandemic but also
remember the protests there's been a ton
of retirements and a lack of new
recruitment so it might not be the best
time to suggest a bunch of firings in
right before the holidays well because
biden's just gonna ram his head against
the wall because the man just is not
flexible enough to deal with a situation
like this reminds me when he proposed to
jill biden eight times
before he got a yes now i'm not saying
that marriage isn't great
but i'm just saying most people wouldn't
have done that most people might have
pivoted and done something differently
and that's what makes great leaders
great leaders are flexible they're
dynamic if you have a general he might
change a strategy when it runs into
resistance in the battlefield a
quarterback dana you know yeah you might
just check down and you know throw it to
the flat and just pick up the first down
that's what good leaders do biden
doesn't do that biden is now facing
labor shortages inflation the crime wave
retirements and all he's doing is just
staring straight ahead like this and we
can't do that there's off ramps you have
religious exemptions you can say we're
going to delay the implementation you
can say work with us we'll pay for
testing it's probably cheaper to pay for
testing daily or weekly than it is to
pay everybody unemployment insurance or
all the taxes you're going to lose when
people are not working
but biden doesn't see that and a lot of
the american people feel like
you're supposed to unite us against the
pandemic and now instead of doing that
you're dividing us against the unvaxed
and that's the problem we have and if
you're going to protest don't cause
traffic that's the one problem
all right geraldo here you go well the
floor is yours i am i consider myself an
open-minded inclusive person i'm friends
with all kinds of people i'm even
friends with greg
barely at this point geraldo but with
700 000 dead
americans
i have zero
patience for people who are not getting
vaccinated i am all for 100 percent in
for vaccine mandates
furthermore
the thing i detest
is vaccinated people
who are cheering on the unvaccinated to
stand up for their freedoms to me that's
why you don't like people standing up
for that that's like
this is this is like the mob
on the street come on telling the person
on the ledge jump jump
when you're vaccinated you want people
to be vaccinated into and to pretend
that it's a it's a civil rights issue
the government supreme court has ruled
on this the the law is settled their
lawsuits will fail
it's a state issue gerald though you
missed it it is not a state issue yes it
is massachusetts is actually in the
title of the ruling greg
because it was one of the parties in the
action i always i'm always happy when my
predictions go correctly my prediction
from the a block that geraldo hates the
unvacs more than he hates the rapist
thank you
dead crap like that so you say things
sometimes that are so crazy
so they made my ears my ears get red and
i just i just i gulp and i say it's
scutfeld and he's kidding around
john oliver i think he either bought or
he sold a 10 million apartment i
remember that was like on the upper west
side or something like that a person who
says go ahead and fire cops can save
that because they live in a place where
he doesn't need them right he doesn't he
doesn't go to the bronx he doesn't go to
harlem he doesn't need to go to the
lower east side where there was just a
horrible violent crime uh in which a
woman was beaten uh he doesn't have that
problem so uh to him a bigger problem
and a bigger own i'm gonna own these
unvast cops is to tell them they get
fired but there are a lot of people that
rely on those police officers that he
never knows we're watching a sleight of
hand again where the medium makes
against matt back's mandates the same as
against the vax i thought the the the
fire chief made it very clear that
that's not what they're talking about
and yes people do have different reasons
for getting vaccinated and different
reasons for not getting vaccinated but
what we're doing right now and i i've
said this to you before geraldo you're
falling for it the media is creating a
duopoly of opinion so you're either
pro-backs or you're some redneck trumper
who wants your family to die that's what
they do but if you look at these
protests the firemen the police officers
if you looked at the protest at barclays
center uh was it after before the
basketball game
as
as
as there is it was like a bet it was
like a benetton ad from 1986. it wasn't
one that's the migrant character it
wasn't it was a so there's a difference
between there's a difference between
protest and conflict and we could
disagree without falling to opposing
camps if you do so you're being
manipulated right that's what i'm saying
and dagon like for the december 8th um
deadline that the president put on this
it's following not just on police
officers but also all these businesses
right before the holidays in the middle
of a supply chain crisis so to jesse's
point
is there any
flexibility here that could be found
well there's no flexibility with geraldo
it's either you're vaccinated or you're
evil and
deserve to will get pushed off the edge
of a building uh it they're not i
guarantee you that my prediction is that
they don't go through with the the
federal order because you're going to
have maybe 25 30 percent of truck
drivers who leave the job but in terms
of
the
these politicians and bureaucrats
particularly with the first responders
the very people who were there uh on the
job every single day at the height of
the pandemic where we didn't even really
know how easily it was spread before the
vaccine even before even before mass
masking
you're going to go out and fire them now
and the calculation these politicians
seem to have made the calculation that a
bigger threat to the public safety
and security is to have 20 to 30 percent
of the police force it's not
on the job and unvaccinated rather than
having 20 to 30 percent fewer cops on
the street protecting people and that is
utter insanity meantime you have john
oliver i guess that from his studio to
his apartment he can roll down the
window on his homeschool aide and throw
some pepper spray and swiss army knives
at the people who have no ability to
protect themselves hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else